للامانه انا انا ما شفت برنامج كان يتكلم
بالتفاصيل لا مسلسل لكن مسلسل الامانه ما
في ما في يعني لو تبي تنصح قصدي واحد تعرف
الشباب الحين ما يطيق يروح يقرا كتاب صح
بس ممكن تقول له والله عندي لك مسلسل
مدري ايش في احدى المنصات ذي ممكن نشوف
حلقات ممكن ممكن
في حلقه تطلع مثال وحده انا اتذكر مره
مثله في طاش عن تفجير الوشم بالذات حلقه
واحده كانت خلال شهر كامل في رمضان فهذا
اللي قاعد اتكلم عنه ما قصروا بس هذا مشهد
يعني او لقطه من لنتكلم ملحمه يعني تتكلم
مسلسل خمسه سته اجزاء عرفت قصدي يعني او
فيلم طويل ساعتين ساعه ونص
انا انا بالنسبه لي ما قد شفت
الوقت مثل ما قلت
كنت توك يعني ما انت مستوعب بس اللي صار
يعني انا لدرجه انك تقول انك انت تخيل انه
حادث تفجير عادي ممكن تفجير غاز ولا تفجير
سياره عاديه ولا وين الخلل يا احمد والله
الخلل يعني متعدد اولا هناك حاله كسل
عدم ايضا ربما جزء كبير عدم ادراك خطوره
ما عشناه
وان هذا كانه ناس صدفه وانقضى
رغم ان ما اشرنا له في الحلقه بعض الاماكن
انه هناك ارتباطات ما بين الفكر والجزر
وما بين هذه التحولات حتى ان حينما انتهت
القاعده خرج داعش وحينما جاء داعش ذهب الى
المساجد وذهب وهذا النقطه الخطيره
حتى يعني انت تتحدث عن حينما تعتقد ان
القاعده واسقطناها بالتاكيد على المستوى
الامني لكنها عادت بعد سنوات بوجه داعش
وهو اصلا
ابن للقاعده